so last night I was watching uh this
project that you did together and this
fascinates me because first of all this
thing looks it's it's beautifully done
this project yeah it's funny because you
probably grew up in an area where there
in an era Kurt where there's there's TV
and then there's film and I think we're
in this world now where stuff that comes
out on TV streaming Apple you look at it
and you think this is cinema this is
it's so beautifully done uh and it's
it's just a different World well that's
what you know when when this this came
to us to to look at Monarch Legacy of
monsters yeah and it was Godzilla so you
know first of all
you Godzilla Godzilla or you know it's
like what you mean which Godzilla no no
the the refined God and that's what we
were in yeah we were we were like well
you know but what you know so we started
talking about it because it was It was
obviously it could be epic it could be
cool um I love I I'd seen Godzilla when
I was probably eight or nine years old
and never forgot him but um it just
became you know the movies are are about
the monsters you see them that's what it
is and it's fantastic you know in a
certain way for a certain audience they
love it but um we also you know when
went came to us we started talking about
it we said you know that's not something
we would probably want to be interested
in doing because it's just not I don't
know it's not doesn't doesn't hit us um
but that was not what they were wanting
to do they were wanting to look at this
thing and take the human
The Human Condition that was living with
it and and do a real true
sci-fi where it's a it's a relatable
Human Experience and there are people
who are dealing with this and uh that
was very interesting to us and so uh
yeah we started talking about it and and
ended up uh you know ended up doing it
and loving that we did it because it
really the fact that Apple would put
this kind of effort into it the fact
that the showrunner and the headwriter
were as invested in it as they they were
the fact that they really went out to
get really good good actors to do it
made us feel like uh yeah this is
something that maybe we should we should
seriously take a look at and we'd have
the opportunity to do something nobody
had ever done that with two known actors
father and son playing the same person
yeah that's the part that blows me away
is uh you are the younger self you are
the uh more mature self yeah slightly
older I say more mature wiser
um well but no no somehow less wise
uh but it's it's really cool that you
you're both playing the same character
and so I would think if you're preparing
for a role like that you're kind of be
going to be eyeing each other you don't
have scenes together because that's not
possible obviously but you're going to
be trying to figure out each other's
physicality I mean I'm guessing that
might be part of it that was that was
sort of the unspoken thing that was in
the back of our heads the whole time
right um the thing that was fascinating
for me uh cuz Wyatt was going to be
different was uh was first of all the
opportunity to watch him work MH and how
he worked and the things that it would
remind me of or things that I would
learn from him watching him but I've
never done a character where somebody
else was starting it out yeah it's like
wait a minute we we talked about this
with the guy not having a big Lim and
now I see you limping around I me okay I
don't I don't have a
limp
and so whatever yeah he whatever he lays
out there because it's you it's you in
the 1950s whatever he lays out there you
have to pick up on so just to be mean to
you he could drool a lot that's what I
mean that's exactly drool all the time
it's like and scratch his face like this
and it's like pick up on that old man I
better see that in your role that's
exactly right I mean it's funny but it's
also like well okay I'm G to have to do
what you know and so we the thing about
it is that let why I talked to it
because he he he he really you know he's
absolutely fantastic in the show and I
love seeing the reaction to him in it um
he he was going to establish these
things that that we were going to do so
we we had to be in line his rhythm his
we have idiosyncrasies that are the same
you know familial things we knew that
those would be there and then we we'd
work on the look and kind of this and
that but uh it was really the fact that
we have different rhythms that was
something we were going to have to deal
with you know and and find and then what
you find yourself in doing in that is
finding a character that you you really
want to play but I mean it was fun to go
down to his set watch him work do you
get intimidated at all if you're I mean
first of all you know my dad's a
microbiologist so it's not like he would
you know I but I would still if I knew
my dad was in the audience when I was
doing a show it felt like more pressure
you know even if there's 7,000 people in
the crowd if I know my dad's there too
because it's my dad felt like a level of
but I don't know if you had that when
when your dad's watching you um there's
I think early on there was a sense of
like yeah I want my dad to think that
I'm good you know like I'm a good actor
or whatever um and then there'd be
things he'd see or that I'd write and he
be like no okay like when in the
beginning um and so yeah you always want
that to be part of it but I learned I
think beyond my dad and getting a little
bit of success in film and also in
hockey it was the same thing like you
just can't do it for that otherwise like
you will sink yourself your whole life
it just will suck you dry like you'll
never that's an insatiable desire that
you cannot um Quench and so I really
started going down the road of like no
I'm I really am just going to do what I
want to do and if it like I said earlier
if it doesn't work it doesn't work and
if my dad doesn't like it like that
doesn't mean that it doesn't work it's
just you know but he's been always so
supportive of it wasn't ever something
that like he that
that they were just great parents I mean
they were they always wanted us to do
well they were always supportive uh and
then they also disassociated from it
enough to where it was like hey it's
great work if you can get it but I'm not
going to be in your hair about this
stuff all the time cool and we never
talk talk about it you know this was the
most we'd ever talked about film outside
of you know being on a movie Set It was
like we had to talk about it a lot
because you had the like make sure the
character was congruent and point A to
point B even Arc and you got to like hit
those spots and stuff like that so it
was really fun to work with them off
camera um seeing how he I'd seen how
he'd worked all the time when people
would come over to the house and I'd be
playing a video game or watching sports
center or something and you'd hear
meetings right and then all he ever did
in those meetings was trying to make the
movie better never was it about like me
me me it was just not the way he is
wasn't the way and it seemed like a good
way to do it because his movies were
always cool and people loved them and
they were always good you're the movie's
good you're going to be good and so I
took that approach and then as I moved
on with my career that's been good for
me and worked for me and now we were
able to do it together and it was
awesome you know it was really fun to be
able to do funny story about the God
about getting cast as Godzilla though my
our Doula who Doula for those of you who
don't know they' help you deliver your
child mhm uh she was with my wife and I
we were getting the offer to do Godzilla
and I have like a relatively large
jaw um you can't see it without my beard
ever since Jason Russell and so yeah and
the D and my wife goes yeah he's gonna
do Godzilla him and Kirk gonna do
Godzilla why it's gonna be in Godzilla
and the dla goes oh my God he's going to
be so great as Godzilla
that
I always pictured him with that jaaw and
I'm
like I'm not playing look so much he's
such a radioactive
lizard like oh no that would be great
if if you agreed to it thinking it was
this other thing and it's your dad doing
all this complex acting and you in a
rubber suit
going your dad's like you you're killing
it doing a really good J way to go
son I'm proud of
you uh well this is uh man this is
extremely cool uh for me because this is
a double treat I've as you know long
been a huge fan of yours uh and we've
talked about it many times even some of
the movies that people don't all know
I've watched those movies like bone
Tomahawk and said man uh that
conversation I will go see if you're in
it I go see it and I never regret it and
then uh as as a to get to meet you cuz I
really love your work I love what you're
doing and I also you're you are so much
your own person and uh and it's very
it's very satisfying for me to like get
to meet your your uh your son I keep
wandering around the neighborhood
because I know you live nearby and I
always see this bearded guy kind of see
me and then duck behind a
head well next time
next time I'll wear bells and you can
hear me good it's like a bear you're
like a bear I have to make noise around
you so you don't attack me right do you
ever see Sandler Adam Sandler lives in
our neighborhood Adam bought our old
house that's right and this is what Adam
does you know it's La so people are
supposed to you know you call first you
send a text maybe we'll get together at
a neutral it's not like that's a weird
thing about La people just don't go over
to other people's houses and ring the
bell right except for Sandler s will
come and stand outside my house and go
Cody
Cody it's like street car Named Desire
he's
yelling and I'll open the door like what
he's like how's it going buddy and then
he says everything's the best do a it's
the best it's the best did you know that
Kurt Russell and Goldie Li yeah they're
the best you seen Wyatt he's the
best you ever had botulism it's the best
the best of the diseases
buddy and then he takes off again yeah
but uh well thanks for saying that I
know I know how hard it is for you to be
Earnest I appreciate
it